el día de hoy vengo a hablarles sobre
una idea que va de la mano con un
fenómeno que impacta alrededor del mundo
tanto a las ciudades en crecimiento como
a las grandes metrópolis el avance
económico y el exponencial crecimiento
del número de habitantes en las ciudades
del presente nos ha obligado a crear
cada vez más espacios destinados al
intercambio de bienes y servicios
actualmente las ciudades sus dirigentes
y la población misma aprecia como
símbolo de desarrollo la construcción de
grandes plazas comerciales donde puedan
adquirir los productos y servicios que
satisfacen las necesidades básicas y
otras no tan básicas del consumismo
actual es así es de esta manera como los
conceptos de convivencia y esparcimiento
en las nuevas ciudades se ven alterados
totalmente alterados las familias
planean su tiempo libre en base a la
disponibilidad de cajones en el
estacionamiento de su centro comercial
preferido el cual se ha convertido en
una especie de centro de reunión
y el cual también tiene que preocuparse
ahora no solamente de vender sino
incluso de programar actividades y
festivales completos para las familias
que los visitan dichas familias no
siempre adquieren los productos que
están exhibidos en los aparadores si nos
instalamos un fin de semana en uno de
estos nuevos puntos de encuentro
podremos observar familias completas
deambular simplemente por estas
instalaciones con el único fin de pasar
un buen rato fuera de casa salir de la
rutina o lo que es un poco más
preocupante pasar un buen rato de
calidad con la familia
porque llevar a cabo estos planes en un
recinto que está pensado y diseñado
exclusivamente para las compras
recuerdo como un buen domingo y espero
no estar sonando demasiado nostálgico ya
que lo que me trae aquí no es el pasado
sino una visión del futuro pero recuerdo
a los miembros de mi familia respirando
aire fresco en las principales áreas
verdes del parque central de mi ciudad
toda la convivencia giraba en torno a
una manta colocada en el suelo compartir
deliciosa comida y escuchar atentamente
las anécdotas de la abuela la cual
mediante estas anécdotas nos ilustraba
acerca de lo diferente que lucía el
mismo parque durante su niñez y nos
hablaba acerca de la audacia del
visionario fundador de la ciudad que lo
convirtió en realidad
aún hoy en día tengo muy fresca esta
imagen puedo conectarme con estos
momentos y puedo recordar cómo es que
estas anécdotas me hacían preguntarme me
hacían viajar en el tiempo y
cuestionarme cómo se vería el mismo
parque cuando yo creciera tal cual me lo
contaba mi abuela
me hace preguntarme cómo se vería y me
hacía de cierta manera anhelar regresar
a él en unos años más y conectarme con
estas imágenes en mi infancia y claro
que ese señor tan visionario y audaz no
ojalá algún día yo con mis esfuerzos
pudiera ser algo similar por mi ciudad
quién sabe el hecho es que en las
ciudades actuales necesitan una
reestructura necesitan pensarse y
diseñarse en relación a su elemento
fundamental los ciudadanos
actualmente sabemos mucho más acerca del
entorno favorable para la vida de los
osos polares que el entorno favorable
para la vida de los seres humanos dentro
de las ciudades los seres humanos
necesitamos recreación esparcimiento y
convivencia para liberar estrés y para
conectar con los demás sumado al
constante trabajo del sentido de
pertenencia
el sentido de pertenencia podría
traducirse como la identidad del
ciudadano y lo que lo une a la ciudad
donde vive donde se desarrolla o bien a
la cual debe sus raíces
es por esto que al igual que muchos
urbanistas alrededor del mundo coincido
con que las ciudades necesitan contar su
historia a través de sus edificios
hacer partícipes tanto a sus habitantes
como a sus visitantes de sus orígenes y
su transformación
toda ciudad tiene sobre su trazo
espacios que fueron fundamentales
durante su fundación y desarrolló
espacios que poco a poco son rodeados o
reemplazados incluso por otros espacios
que poco o absolutamente nada tienen que
ver con la identidad de los habitantes y
su historia
la recuperación de estos espacios
debería significar una prioridad tanto
para los dirigentes como para la
sociedad misma no hay que dejarle todo a
los dirigentes la sociedad también tiene
que empoderarse en este tema son estos
espacios los que guardan la esencia del
surgimiento de una nueva ciudad como lo
lograron nuestros antepasados cuáles
fueron los cimientos que dieron lugar a
lo que hoy conocemos al asentamiento de
familias de centros productivos de
dinastías completas en fin al origen
prueba irrefutable de lo que les
comparto sucedió en nuestro país durante
la segunda de la segunda mitad de la
década de los 80s
el nuevo león
en 1986 y tras nueve años como una
empresa paraestatal fundidora monterrey
es declarada en quiebra
suena familiar
dos años después durante la primera
mitad de 1988
desde que es publicado en el diario
oficial de la federación el decreto
presidencial para la expropiación de los
de los terrenos de la ahora extinta
fundidora monterrey s a
para la construcción de un parque museo
en 1988 también en la segunda mitad de
este año en noviembre de 1988 nace
constitutivamente el fideicomiso parque
fundidora
con esfuerzos de la iniciativa privada y
el gobierno del estado de nuevo léon
donde se define la misión del parque su
vocación y sus siete ejes
entretenimiento esparcimiento ecológico
educativo deportivo negocios y cultural
actualmente parque fundidora es un
parque urbano incluyente y
multifuncional que contribuye a reforzar
el tejido social ofreciendo un espacio
verde seguro y de acceso 100% gratuito
incluso se le ha otorgado el título de
museo de sitio de arqueología industrial
por el valor histórico de las 27 macro
estructuras 127 piezas siderúrgicas y
herramientas que hoy son piezas
museográficas 16 naves y un sinfín de
activos que conforman un acervo que
significa un patrimonio industrial
invaluable on
en 1898 100 años antes de esto
pero aquí en nuestra ciudad en los
mochis benjamín francis johnston
contador privado estadounidense ha
traído en 1890 por el proyecto de ciudad
de albert que owen colocó la primera
piedra de lo que sería el edificio de
una de las fábricas de azúcar más
importantes del noroeste de la república
mexicana
el ingenio azucarero produjo el
crecimiento demográfico de los mochis
la compañía azucarera de los mochis o el
ingenio como mejor se le conoce tiene
para todos los que vivimos aquí un valor
histórico innegable su historia es la
historia de nuestra ciudad la fundación
y crecimiento del ingenio propiciaron el
nacimiento de los mochis
hace ya varios años que la ciudad de los
vientos con olor a caña
dejo de oler a caña
el ingenio no volverá a funcionar
el silbido del ingenio no volverá a
anunciarnos la caída de la zafra y la
empresa que dio vida por más de 100 años
a esta ciudad
hasta aquí llego
en palabras del conocido historiador
local alfredo salazar hermosillo
dicho todo lo anterior
los invito a cerrar los ojos
pero si alguno de ustedes no se siente
cómodo en la oscuridad
basta con que activen su imaginación
y proyecten un poquito hacia el futuro
y realicen un proyecto de reciclaje
arquitectónico industrial imaginen el
corazón de nuestro mochis rehabilitado
imaginen a familias completas
conviviendo todos los días con la
historia de su ciudad aprendiendo cómo
es que absolutamente todo lo que conocen
ahora surgió
de una barra de caña a 350 km o más al
norte del trópico de cáncer una de las
mayores hazañas del ingenio azucarero de
los mochis pues según los técnicos esto
muy difícilmente puede lograrse ya que
la caña de azúcar tiene sus más altos
rendimientos tanto del campo como de
fábrica al sur de esta línea geográfica
imaginaria
imaginen las chimeneas en su momento el
terror de las amas de casa ya no
esparciendo safra sino cultura e
historia contactando a las nuevas
generaciones con sus raíces con el
esfuerzo de hombres y mujeres que se
distinguieron por su capacidad de
trabajo su identidad y su conexión con
la empresa que en su época dorada fue la
empresa perfecta
fue perfecta porque tuvo excelentes
empleados que lograron el surgimiento de
un proyecto de ciudad
en momentos históricos de transición
como los que estamos viviendo
actualmente en el mundo en el país en
nuestras familias en nuestras
conciencias está en manos de los
ciudadanos
imaginar y crear las ciudades del futuro
está en mis manos está en sus manos
imaginar una ciudad en contacto con su
historia
recuperemos nuestros símbolos nuestro
orgullo
recuperemos nuestra identidad hagamos
una realidad esta visión hagamos una
realidad el parque ingenio
mi nombre es luis daniel cordero y el
día de hoy quiero que después de esta
plática algunos afortunados se lleven a
su casa un pedacito de historia los
invito a revisar debajo de sus asientos
gracias
[Aplausos]